what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm John Humphrey
[Music]
I'm so alone what is shake and rejects
of the nation yes it is me John Humphrey
where's Gregg you asked he is away with
his lady companion on a little vacay
much needed times have been a little
thick lately so I'm holding down the
fort so for the most parts it's gonna be
me and you're gonna have to deal with
that me and the four cats I got them
editing videos and I'm gonna check out
some new Star Wars because this morning
the Disney YouTube channel dropped a
rise of Skywalker clip as well as a
special look before we happen to this
just wanted to say thanks to everybody
who's been checking us out on the
patreon patreon comm slash the real
rejects is where you can go if you love
this channel if you want to help support
and take advantage of some of our
exclusive content we do Q&A is weekly TV
show reaction stream alongs for a bunch
of shows some of those shows have
reaction highlights included ten minutes
of footage cut down so you don't have to
worry about the sink if you don't want
to and if you want to get our first
opinion on the latest movies as well as
trailers and stuff we don't cover here
and go ahead and check us out on the
stardust app as well now let's get into
this hmm funny it reminds me of that
first teaser
thing comes up over there
Oh ray with a blaster
[Music]
whoa that's a cook all right hmm
self-aware humor maybe this is cool this
is you know not the most substantial
clip in the world but as far as
rip-snorting rollicking star wars action
goes especially on the heels of the
Mandalorian I must wonder if that's why
they put this particular clip out is
just due this year popularity of the
Mandalorian and maybe in some kind of
subconscious way they are using the
desert setting of this and the shootout
cat-and-mouse chase element Star Wars oh
it borrowed in some regard from westerns
but this definitely feels like something
that wants to harken to the goodwill
that that has built but hey I mean
there's a cool clip I mean there's how
much to say about it the design is cool
that first shot did remind me of Finn
coming over the ridge in the force
awakens teased that first time I like
the just while we're here while we're
still talking about Star Wars
I like the upgrades they've made to the
stormtrooper armor and stuff like that
really just appreciating especially as
the stakes surrounding just the quality
of this film loom and affect the
anticipation process I do really lose
myself I think the most I get the most
joy out of just like soaking in these
images and looking at the designs and
stuff I know we talk about that a lot
these cruisers are cool I like this
launch pad bike they've got this like
catapult bike the stormtroopers are on
jet packs are funtime I mean you know
it's a reasonable upgrade I guess and
it's cool to see ray you know throwing
down with a blaster from all the footage
we've seen and I don't know how long
this movies gonna be but it certainly
seems as though this movie's gonna
traverse a lot of different areas and
territories you've got Rey alone doing
the training thing at one point then
you've got everyone together here are
their stuff in space does look very
sprawling from these glimpses that we're
getting and yeah it's pretty cool it's
not much of a scene really I mean it
just hints that okay this is probably
gonna be a cool extended action sequence
when the actual movie hits and you know
the bit at the end with the whole I got
jet packs now that's alright I feel like
it's gonna have to obviously breathe in
scene it does smack a little bit of
popular self-aware humor that everybody
loves right now and kind of awkward
comic timing but you know that's this is
obviously engineered to give you a 30
second breath of feelings about this
movie or flavors from it but anyway
let's move on to these Star Wars rides
of Skywalker a special look and wash
ourselves in some Mora nostalgia here we
go dude it is always awesome to see the
droids like the word star 11 years old
who's in a magazine and I've ever seen
the words and saying aloud Star Wars
[Music]
Star Wars that was just an important
part of everyone's history
[Music]
when I sat outside the theater to watch
them at midnight with my dad a lot
higher the imaginations of every sinner
alone who yearns for adventure people's
love for it it's just nothing
it's the event that has become a
cultural phenomenon
[Music]
so was that the mouse them football the
first is the stance
[Music]
something people carry with them now
revenue
we were there do you remember where you
were with my glasses
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
others you're glad that you're finishing
but savoring every moment because you
know is the last ah you know it is them
you know it is the last that's an
interesting sentiment to leave that off
on I mean this is ostensibly the last of
the Skywalker saga films yes although
even that to me it's to be see because I
don't know I mean the thing is I don't
know I'm not gonna go off into a tangent
I think this was really nice and it's
funny this reminded me a lot of video we
just watched that as if this posting is
not edited enough yet but it will be in
the next day or two
the Patrick H Williams video essay about
how Star Wars trailers weaponized
nostalgia and these both this but
especially this little special look here
got me thinking back to that video
because he doesn't really excellent
breakdown just of how they use the
different themes from the scores to the
different films as well as different
kinds of images and the way that they
build an ebb and flow of emotion with
that and I thought about that a lot
during this special look just because it
does obviously borrow from images across
time not so much across the early
two-thousands when the prequels were
coming out there's a little bit of that
footage in here
but you know I thought this was at least
a nice little ode to just the place in
culture that Star Wars holds I mean I
know it's easy to be cynical about Star
Wars in some ways I get that way
sometimes just because Star Wars is
responsible for so much of how the movie
industry works and how movies themselves
especially on a mass scale operate and
it's funny because you know there's a
double-edged sword to that but what's
something like this is nice at reminding
us about or at least me about is how
nice it is that we can all share so like
I get it's just a movie it's just a
story but I do think that there is in
the right context and importance to that
and it's nice to see how everybody from
top to bottom from just people taking in
the movies and really enjoying them and
supporting them to the people who are
helming them all share this kind of
magical feel like if anybody cares about
Star Wars and I'm not even the world's
biggest Star Wars fan
I appreciate Star Wars and there's
definitely a lot about it I do really
enjoy and love I definitely grew up on
the original films as like a staple of
my young life so I feel like there's a
certain just aura that you think of and
I wonder also - you could probably look
at how Lucasfilm Disney etc have
sculpted this over time but this
definitely felt like that sort of the
best of Star Wars you know this this
congregational love and the way that it
is impacted and touched and sort of sent
its tendrils out towards so many
different avenues of our culture you
look behind the scenes with things like
movie merchandising and franchising and
stuff like that but just the way that
yeah it has seeped its way into the
cultural lexicon it's and all these
sitcoms and stuff they even acknowledge
Spaceballs especially there are moments
for Peter Mayhew and Carrie Fisher in
here you know you got Obama you got her
even President Reagan from back in the
day Family Guy stuff on the news there's
a little nod to reaction videos and
stuff like that didn't make it into this
comp didn't make him into this
compilation but that's okay and Anna now
you've got people who were growing up as
fans who are now into movies and leading
them forward and like geeking out when
Harrison Ford signs somebody's hanoi you
know it is sweet in a way as much as
yeah you can get cynical about you know
evil Lord business and stuff like that I
love the inclusion of like the
astronauts the little Lego Star Wars set
up Homer spoiling the ending which is
great too because like that even
acknowledges in a small way just the
cultural impact on the holes
conversation around spoilers Star Wars
is one of the most famously spoiled
films of all time and so yeah they even
have Homer in there I thought it was
just a really nice like this does kind
of sweep certain things under the rug or
or not bother to remind you of certain
things about Star Wars we don't all
necessarily love but I thought they did
at least do a nice job of spreading it
around to different areas not just from
within but also the different cheeky
ways it's impacting culture and stuff
like that and now this has me thinking
about like my first comic-con my buddy
Aaron who I used to do the dank ass dubs
with saw attack the block at an early
screening in Joe Cornish and John boyega
were both there and on some old
telephone of mine I have like a grainy
picture of me and John boyega from way
back in the day so so that's that's you
know pretty rad to see him they like it
shoot up and all these other people -
yes pretty fun so yeah what do you guys
think did you enjoy this clip are you
still looking forward to the rise of
Skywalker are you still not looking
forward to the rise of Skywalker leave
your thoughts down there and how did you
feel about the special look do you share
this nostalgia or do you think that this
is you know just a manipulative way to
reinforce the fan culture man whatever
it is leave it in the comments and yeah
you can subscribe to the reject nation
hit that notification about to get
updated every time a review or a video
is out if you'd be so kind as to check
us out on patreon if you love the
channel and want to help support that
would be amazing also the Stardust app
much love to all of you guys and before
we wrap this up I want to give it quick
patron of a shout out to my good friend
Erica Tuesday Erica is a badass artiste
she's working on some awesome stuff
right now that I hope y'all get to see
with your eyeballs in the near future
but uh Erica you've been in stuff before
I mean you've popped up animated and
Bojack horseman and things like that but
I think you would be a prime star war a
star war you would be a great star war
if you had like a cool yeah I could
totally imagine you with like some kind
of cool band in G arm thing and then
some kind of neat hooded smock ish getup
and you know some kind of an interesting
weapon of future sorts you know hanging
out in a dune you know surveying a
desert landscape maybe eating a lizard
or something and then you know doing
something on a cool badass speed bike I
feel like that could be pretty fun so
getting good with the Disney people and
get yourself you know inserted into
maybe like one of the animations or
something like that I think that would
be really cool anyway shout out